as president Trump prepares for that
trip Iranians are voting for a new
president the two leading candidates
have different views of Iran's
relationship with the West and the 2015
deal to limit its nuclear program
Elizabeth Palmer is in Tehran iran's
capital city Elizabeth good morning good
morning
well voting is well underway here in
Iran long lines outside the polling
stations to some extent this election is
a referendum on the nuclear deal
millions of Iranians were very much in
favor of it they wanted it to bring
better relationships with the United
States and the rest of the world along
with the tide of foreign investment
which has not so far materialized
conservatives though think it was a
sellout and that Iran should never have
accepted any limits on its nuclear
program there's little reliable polling
data here in Iran but President rouhani
is expected to win by a narrow margin if
he doesn't and hardliner
becomes president the United States in
that case could certainly expect a more
hostile Iran especially as the Trump
administration has already made it clear
that it neither trusts nor likes the
government here in Tehran Gayle Thank
You Elizabeth Palmer and Tehran